welcome back to New Rock starss I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Five
Nights at Freddy's the 2023 film based
on the game series of a Chuck-E-Cheese
inspired kids eery arcade where horrible
things happen this movie was designed
for YouTube horror Easter egg hunters to
devour so let's break this down scen by
scene for the Easter eggs you might have
missed and not just nods to the games
but to other great pop horror like
scream and it and a lot of people that
you have seen on this platform by the
way new rock stars is going to be doing
a live show in Los Angeles and brain
dead Studios I'm going to be there come
hang out with me it's going to be a lot
of fun ticket info is in the description
okay in the opening seconds we see a few
video glitches over the opening
Universal logo the bloomhouse logo just
like the video monitor throughout the
games and throughout this film over
black we hear the sound of a squeaking
screw and we see the previous security
guard rushing to open an air vent to
escape now this guard was going to be
played by YouTuber Markiplier but he had
to turn down the role due to some
scheduling conflicts with his own film
iron lung this security guard would be
the guy in the game who leaves voice
recordings for you the guy who had the
job before you do in the security office
we see the celebrate poster just as
there is in the security office in the
games there's also a metal fan there's a
red and white striped drinking cup they
really just got the attention to detail
perfect this whole idea of fleeing an
unseen monster through Vince having only
a flashlight recalls the death of Dallas
an alien as well as the humans fleeing
the xenomorph Warriors throughout the
vents and the follow-up aliens but in
the Five Nights at Freddy's games vents
just kind of show up a lot but largely
in Sister location and in Freddy
Fazbear's pizzeria simulator where he
can only get to the security office by
coming in through the vents but the
guard is grabbed and he's locked in this
chair as sharp Gears of the interior of
the animatronic mask lower down upon his
face we actually see the poor guard's
face framed through the mouth like the
creature is devouring him this is
exactly the kind of Fate that the voice
recording of the past security guard
warns you about in the game now as the
guard nearly wriggles free the eye
pieces is narrow the red light for the
pup's shrinking as if the animatronic is
onto him actually the metallic Spike
spiral of these irises opening and
closing reminds me of the greasy metal
apertures of the Nostromo air vents an
alien then we see kids drawings
depicting the kid ghosts who haunt the
animatronics including Cassidy that's
golden Freddy Gabriel Freddy Jeremy
Bonnie Fritz foxy and Susie Chica and in
the middle of all these you see yellow
rabbit holding their hands ominously but
there's also a drawing of a kid labeled
David which I was wondering might be a
nod to David Miller That's William
aton's fake name in the book The Silver
Eyes now in the game kids draw like this
are inside the security office but here
in the movie they're kind of out on
display in the main part of the pizzeria
the opening credits are awesome of this
movie they dep pick these 8bit pixel
arts of a video game which look exactly
like the Five Nights at Freddy's arcade
mini games that you play Within the game
we see the five kids from Mike's
recurring dreams the ghost kids but we
also see a dark figure the purple guy
putting on the yellow rabbit costume AKA
spring Bonnie and the first time we see
it which actor's name appears over this
Matthew Lillard written in the color
purple he's the purple guy the way he
lowers the mask over his head is exactly
the way William does it in the Final Act
of this movie in the game the wearer of
the puppet suit is a mysterious purple
guy that's why he's known as a purple
guy and really anytime The Color Purple
just shows up you know spring Bonnie's
coming we see the yellow rabbit figure
taking the kids away one by one and as
he comes to the last kid notice the claw
and the claw machine in the background
hanging over the toys I love this detail
because really the plan is to claw these
kids into the suits as their bodies rot
actually in the corner of that claw
machine game you can see a purple face
with black and white eyes and a crooked
smile which is very similar to the face
we often see on the purple guy okay 6:
a.m. actually first we just see the
digital numbers in a black void and then
in the context of the nightstand clock
in this sunlit room but 6 a.m. on a
black screen is really the recurring
time in the games when your shift is
over means you survive the night but
really throughout this movie time is
just a key component as on Mike's first
night his very first shift we see it is
3:00 a.m. on the clock and the game
nothing happens at first night until
Bonnie moves at 3:00 a.m. also on Mike's
nightstand it's a frame photo of Mike
Schmid and his brother Garrett and their
parents but there's a medication bottle
for leprosa Lam which is a sleep
medication setting up Mike's recurring
sleep issues but this is also similar to
the pill bottle on the side of the bed
and Five Nights at Freddy's 4 we also
see a copy of the book called dream
theory which comes back throughout this
movie it's a reference to the most
popular fan theory for the game series
that the events of Five Nights at
Freddy's 1 through 3 are really a dream
we later get a close-up of the cover
showing that this is the fifth
translation I don't know what to make of
that maybe it's a no did this being a
followup to Five Nights at Freddy's 4 I
don't know but the cover art shows a
maze with an easily accessible Center
and then on the corner a white rabbit
logo which I thought could be a
reference to lwi Caroll Adventures in
Wonderland following the White Rabbit
down the hole which also got referenced
in a similar reality bending Dream movie
The Matrix it could also be a reference
to vany the main antagonist of security
breach who wears a patchwork white bunny
suit with glowing red eyes on Mike
ceiling is a a Nebraska poster in the
games a Nebraska Freddy's location is
mentioned but the main events of the
Freddy's location are in Utah Mike's
little sister Abby sleeps in a tent in
her next room like Cole in the sixense
always spending a lot of time in a tent
both kids seem to be pursued by ghosts
Mike's cooworker Jeremiah reads this
dream theory book and though the dreamer
remains asleep he walks through memory
as if experiencing it for the first time
a new no longer a passenger but an
active participant this really is the
Thematic basis of this film and it's the
way Mike believes that he can revisit
memories to experience them actively to
relive his brother's abduction to learn
who took him and though he's hesitant to
admit it to try to change the past which
obviously something you can't do now in
this ice cream shop in the mall the
rainbow that forms the shop logo is
actually the same rainbow from chica's
miname and Five Nights at Freddy's
worlds Mike sees a kid who reminds him
of Garrett being taken aggressively by
his dad thinking that it's another
abduction and he tackles into the
fountain the man who we actually learned
is the boy's real father but the kid he
first sees versus the kid in reality
when he flashes back to this moment
later these are two different kids Mike
just saw him initially as his brother
Garrett it casts this whole movie within
an unreliable narrator perspective we
don't really know if the reality we see
can be trusted now we learned via a
security camera screen that this takes
place on April 6th 2000 since the kids
disappeared in the ' 80s it would need
to be in the year 2000 now for the
timeline to match up but it also gives
this movie a whole nostalgic feel from
our perspective it's we're at the end of
the 99s that decade of the movie Scream
and Chuck-E-Cheese birthday parties but
it's also kind of that weird forgotten
void after the Millennium but before
9/11 the Millennium was kind of a Nexus
point that was cited in screen by Randy
Meeks as something that erases the need
for psychopaths to need a motive kind of
like a centennial full moon Mike meets
Steve career
counselor yeah kind of seems like he's
humming the same song that we heard the
animatronic humming in the opening
attack he's played by Matthew Lillard
whom you'll know from a recent breakdown
of 1996 of scream played Stu who was
spoiler warning for a movie 27 years old
Stu was one of the two killers in that
original screen film for shadowing a
similar twist reveal at the end of this
movie now since the first security guard
dies Steve fills in as kind of the phone
guy giving the first night instructions
which is actually kind of like one of
Matt Pat's early theories where he
thought that the purple guy was the
phone guy and that's kind of what this
movie does in effect here also notice
that Steve wears a purple tie setting
him up as a purple guy Steve perks up
when he realizes Mike's last name is
Schmidt recognizing him as Garrett's
older brother I think and Steve says
that the pay isn't great which is a nod
to the game when you realize that your
paycheck is just for 120 bucks at the
end of the week Mike tries to get Abby
to eat sitting on my friend and he warns
that for kids who don't eat dinner their
bodies stay the same size forever and
she looks back at the spot on the bed
which is likely the blond boy ghost
already targeting this family and that's
what happens when these ghost kids died
their bodies just kind of stayed the
same size forever in his dream Mike
revisits the memory of Garrett's
abduction and we see how the color
yellow is triggering for him the yellow
tent the yellow frisbee that distracted
him from following Garrett the same
color as the yellow rabbit we're also
reminded of Bill denoro and Stephen
King's It who lost his little brother
Georgie to a supernatural abduction
while Georgie was in a yellow raincoat
Georgie was playing with a paper boat
Garrett was playing with a red plane but
notice how this car has no license plate
which I interpret as Mike struggling to
remember details that could help him
track the abductor aby's teach says
before we learn to speak images are the
most important tool we have for
understanding the world around us an
important rule that gets applied
throughout this movie also notice on the
chalkboard the spelling words include
musician puppet bear trophies bunny Fox
and chick all these obviously applying
to Freddy and his side characters and
the dark things they do to their victims
turning them into trophies but again
this is another like weird coincidence
that seems to be happening in the real
world just another clue that like the
movie Shutter Island a lot of what is
presented as reality might be part of a
dream or an illusion or hallucination so
as Mike drives up to Freddy's for the
first time we hear Steve saying over to
the phone the only reason they haven't
given it the old wrecking ball treatment
is the owner is a bit of a well he's
kind of a Sentimental guy I guess yeah
even on the words sentimental we suspect
that he really is a Sentimental one he
warns that the electricity is a bit iffy
which is an odd to how in the game you
have to manage the electricity to keep
the evil out Mike finds an orientation
video with his name already on it in the
background of this video the guy tiering
with the animatronic is Henry Emily the
co-owner from Freddy Fazbear's pizzeria
simulator Henry's daughter Charlotte
Emily was also Williams first victim and
I could be wrong but this guy kind of
looks like the guy who plays Mike's dad
in the flashbacks so maybe Mike is
connected to this by being the son of
Henry Emily later Mike says that after
their mom died their dad quote couldn't
take it anymore and he just kind of
trails off which you know you could read
as you know him ending things or there
could be some other kind of backstory
there the host of this video says the
genius who created Fazbear entertainment
opened Freddy Fazbear's pizzeria to
indulge in his two greatest passions
familyfriendly fun and cuttingedge
animatronic technology yeah the host
looks and sounds completely unhinged
like the creator of this chain described
as a genius and notice how she has a ton
of pieces of flare kind of like that
unhinged waiter at Chach keis in office
space I actually think Steve's shirt and
his glasses are based on Milton from
Office Space the host introduces the
robots
yes in the middle of that static
Freddy's face appears for just a frame
or two the same exact glitch from the
game Mike gets scared by the balloon boy
in the locker balloon boy and Five
Nights at Freddy's 2 would crawl through
the vents and scare you later when Abby
asks hello walking through the arcade
it's the same kind of child like hello
that you hear from balloon boy in the
games hi so just so you guys know I am
busy like all the time I don't have a
ton of time to even sleep so I have to
make sure that when I do lay down I'm
going to get the best sleep possible
which is why I was overjoyed to hear
that today's video is being sponsored by
beams dream powder dream powder is a
super tasty nighttime cocoa available
with or without CBD dream comes in a
variety of truly delicious flavors like
cinnamon cocoa chocolate peanut butter
and sea salt caramel just to name a few
chocolate peanut butter is my favorite
personally but that's just because I
have impeccable taste each serving of
dream powder contains no added sugar is
only 15 calories and depending on what
version you get it contains ingredients
such as melatonin magnesium and
extract to help you fall asleep and get
the most restful sleep possible all
dream powder is gluten-free keto free
non-GMO keto friendly vegan and
delicious oh yeah chocolate peanut
butter right before bed that's a
nighttime routine I can get used to I
fall asleep faster and I wake up feeling
you know it sounds silly but I feel
better just more alert and better rested
and you know better the numbers don't
lie in a clinical study 93% of particip
reported dream helped them get better
sleep click shop beam.com neww rockstars
or scan the QR code to shop beam's
biggest sale and get up to 50% off don't
miss out on this limited time offer
Discount Auto applied no code necessary
we see Mike sleeping on the job in front
of the screens in this overhead shot
dream theory right in front of him kind
of like Neo sleeping in one of the early
shots of the Matrix Mike dreams of the
Five Ghost kids all with their flare
representing the animatronics the bunny
ears the hook hand the Hat the bib
actually later Mike finds Abby sleeping
in a bed with a Golden Bear In Her Arms
o Sparky's Diner is not to Sparky the
dog from the game more on him in a bit
and we get a big Cameo here you do
realize that lunch is the most important
meal of the day hey it's matat congrats
buddy Matt Pat of course longtime
crafter of some amazing Five Nights at
Freddy's theories and they even worked
in his tagline some people say that but
you know it's just a theory are you
being paid by the word actually his name
badge is Ness which is a Nona pads hot
take that Sands is nest on the monitor
screen lightning flashes showing the
shadow of Foxy now compared to the
others foxy is more broken down and I
think that's because in the games there
is an out of order sign on his little
Pirate Cove Side stage so really he
would be broken down for longer than the
rest of them now in the games foxy is
the most unpredictable one you have to
keep him from leaving his area of the
Pirate Cove behind that curtain by
checking it constantly and if you don't
he will escape and Sprint down the
hallway toward the security office and
you only have a second or two to shut
the security door before he gets there
or else he jumps in the room and gets
you in his next stream Mike demands from
them who took
Garrett yeah the camera cuts to the
blonde boy for this one because he would
be the one with the answers but instead
Mike chases the red head and orange
representing foxy and that's why his arm
gets slashed by the hook hand actually
the wound appears on his arm after he
wakes up as well reminding us of another
Freddy Dream movie series Nightmare on
Elm Street you'll notice on the mirror
the words it's me are traced in the dust
the text it's me often appears on the
screen screen of the game and in the
flickering light foxy appears in the
hallway officer Vanessa Shelly checks in
on Mike Now Vanessa is a security guard
in the game originally a programmer from
help wanted and she comes back as a
brainwashed security guard in security
breach in this movie she is rcon to be
William afton's daughter which I think
makes this movie a different continuity
from the game it's widely believed and
pretty much accepted among the fan base
that Mike Schmidt the main character is
William aton's son in the games at least
Vanessa activates Freddy's band and
listen to the music lyrics close your
eyes go to
sleep close your eyes go to sleep it's
just creepy later when Jeff's gang
breaks in to try to get Mike fired from
his job we see Bonnie's eye open on the
security feed and when we come back to
the feed Bonnie is gone and I love how
we see this from the monitor to imply
that this is something this gang would
see if they were just watching closely
as you're supposed to do in the game
also I just love that this same angle on
the two of them of the backstage
animatronics is just the same angle of
that shot from the security monitor in
the game game and Jeff asks Carl good
yeah golden yeah yeah he says golden
poor choice of words considering one of
the animatronics is golden Freddy Carl
actually wears a shirt that looks like
the motorist arcade game from Pizzeria
simulator but his name Carl I think is
no coincidence because chica attacks
Carl using Mr Cupcake to devour his face
and in the games many people nicknamed
Mr Cupcake Carl so I think that's why
the character has that name meanwhile
Hank has been smashing a lot of stuff
including the employees of the month
board and the N has dropped so it looks
like employe of the moth it's kind of
fun because they're both employees of
the moth and employees of the mouth
because some of these guys might have
been devoured by the mouths and now
their bodies are rotting with moths
picking at them am I overthinking it
probably but these photos are all other
YouTubers known for Five Nights at
Freddy's content like you can see Fusion
Z gamer you can see Ras Bowski March is
baz December is AIT Ryan July is Doo
it's so cool that this movie paid credit
to all the YouTubers who did so much to
make this game so popular now when Hank
fleas Bonnie appears behind him in the
Supply Closet which is great because in
the first game Bonnie is the only robot
you can ever find in that closet and
Jeff sees these robots in the Monitor
and they both look at the camera the
same pose from the first five nights at
Freddy's game Max follows this ghost kid
into a room with the remains of an
animatronic dog and I think this could
be Sparky Sparky is the urban legend of
a sixth animatronic who people on Tumblr
would say would sometimes appear in the
backstage doorway but would never attack
you but this is revealed to be a
photoshopped hoax but Max's top half
gets devoured by the animatronic bitten
in half cleanly a reference to the bite
death in the 83 miname Mike shares with
Vanessa his theory that all of our
experiences down to the detail are still
stored inside of us while it is his
belief it is not actually how our minds
store memories folks memories are
malleable and subjective our brain
actually erases and warps memories in a
way that it thinks will benefit our
survival going forward that's why in our
Judicial System we have a right to a
speedy trial because the longer you wait
to people to testify the more likely our
brains biologically and chemically
rewire the way we look at our own pasts
so just because someone recalls
something or cannot recall something
doesn't mean it objectively happened or
it objectively didn't happen Mike has
another dream where the blonde boy draws
up the yellow rabbit in the dirt and he
wakes up to find Abby being tickled
nearly to death by Freddy by Bonnie by
foxy and Chica Mike connects that all of
aby's drawings have representations of
these four robots and they return to the
Pizzeria and the camera pushes in
between the F and the a of Fazbear like
the title shot in The Matrix film when
it's swooped in between the letters they
all build a fort which is crazy Vanessa
finds tablecloths and Mike asks how she
knows where to look because yeah she's
spent a lot of time here as a kid as we
find out later they see a disassembled
animatronic with Rosy Cheeks which could
be circus baby that's a robot hunted by
the soul of Elizabeth Afton the daughter
of William Afton which first appeared in
the Five Nights at Freddy's sister
location and the fact that Vanessa is so
protective of it but it could be the
fact that it has this claw rib cage that
could trap you in and it's dangerous or
could be that the character is a ghost I
don't know she did get stabbed at the
end of the movie and she's in a hospital
but again everything in this movie is
called into question when it's from
Mike's perspective now if this isn't
circus baby I will admit that The Fringe
on the dress and the headpiece kind of
look like those of Ella a character from
the books Mike leaves Abby with Aunt
Jane and Mike revisits his dream and the
ghost kids ask for Abby in exchange for
him being able to see Garrett reunited
with the family in the dream every night
and he almost agrees to it he says he
actually does Mike come on man but he
does reneg but the ghats don't accept it
they attack and Mike wakes up in the
same chair with that saw style death
trap coming in on him he finds the other
bodies there's that dog one that might
be Sparky see Chase's Mike coming a
scattered Pirate song that was actually
performed by Kellen Goff known for his
voice work in the Five Nights at
Freddy's games as Funtime Freddy Freddy
gets Abby from the house and kills Aunt
Jane and when she was watching the TV
it's the same angle as the ending of
sister location with the TV the cap
driver is a cameo by another YouTuber
Corey kinhin who is also known for Five
Nights at Freddy's content tent Vanessa
reveals that she is William aton's
daughter and that the kids bodies are
hidden inside the machines and that's
why the ghosts are connected to them and
notice how her sweater is golden yellow
which I believe ties her visually to the
yellow rabbit when Mike breaks back into
the restaurant they're jamming out and
their song lyrics are once again pretty
[Music]
frightening don't you know you're
sleeping as then again could all of this
be Mike dream Mike tases Freddy Fazbear
and Bonnie while chica tries to put Abby
in the shell for a circus baby I think
that's what it is Mr Cupcake bites
Mike's leg but he prods Mr Cupcake foxy
stalks Abby and Mike runs into the
yellow rabbit himself which is partly
based on Spring Bonnie from the game
which was an early version of Bonnie
that was introduced in Five Nights at
Freddy's 3 the main Persona of William
Apton who later becomes the identity of
springtrap the first light that hits his
character when he's revealed is purple
this rabbit wipes a knife with his
fingers which is another not to scream
when St wearing the ghost face mask
pretending to kill Billy Lumis during
the party he wipes the fake blood off
the knife just like this and when he
unmasks himself Matthew Lillard plays a
villain with the same unhinged acting
style pointing the knife to make a point
just as Stu does in Scream William tells
Vanessa that she had one job keep him in
the dark and kill him if he got too
close and she snaps back that's two jobs
calling back Mike's rort in the earlier
scene and you only have to worry about
one thing keeping people out and and you
know and keep the place tidy that's two
things Abby draws a new picture to show
the kid ghosts what William really did
and they turn on him Mr Cupcake takes a
bite out of his side and his rib claws
jab his stomach causing him to bleed out
and he says I always come back I'll be
right back yeah I'm sure his ghost or
even maybe a physical form of himself
will come back in the sequel especially
since William Aton Never Dies and in the
final shot of the movie we see the
yellow rabbit twitching just like he
does for 30 years in Five Nights at
Freddy's 4 so despite this first movie
being set in the year 2000 this guy
could return in a sequel set in our
present day in a mid- credit scene Cory
kenshi returns as balloon boy gets in
his cab and over the very end of the
credits is this creepy audio
m e yes the letter spell out come find
me and what's really fun in
international versions of this movie
they spell out different letters for
whatever that language translation of
come find me is so whose voice is this I
think it might be the voice of Garrett
because we never actually found
Garrett's body in this movie I think
William Aton put Garrett's body in one
of the animatronic puppets have seen
this Channel's past in-depth breakdowns
of the trailers of this movie by Anna
vanston who did an incredible job with
an amazing attention to detail please
subscribe to her Channel goom for her
amazing gaming related content her
Theory videos she's going to have the
best Five Nights at Freddy's videos on
YouTube trust me please support new
rockstars by grabbing a shirt from nerd
rot. shop like this Loki OB inspired
we're all going to die shirt please
subscribe to all three channels on the
new Rockstar Network this channel new
rockstars the breakroom and the Deep
dive big thanks to Eric Seline for his
help researching this video you can
follow me on all social platforms at
eaos thanks for watching I'll see you
next time
bye